When you are reading Piazza,
there are a couple of different
ways you can navigate.
First, there's the topic list that
we've been using on the left.
Second, you can filter
by folders at the top.
For example, here are all of
the topics in the project folder.
The numbers indicate the number
of updated posts in each folder.
Clicking a folder shows only
those topics in that folder.
Third, you can use the search bar.
The search bar allows you to search
by key words or by certain flags.
After you start typing a search query,
click the search tips to
bring up a list of flags.
For example,
you can search within titles, or for
specific contributors by name.
Note that sometimes the folder listing
across the top won't list every folder.
In those cases,
you can search by folder here.
>> My favorite navigation features,
though,
are found under this gear right here.
This menu lets you view only
certain types of messages.
For example, you can view only newly
created topics by clicking on Unread,
or you can view only updated
topics by clicking on Updated.
You can choose to view only instructor
posts by clicking on Instructor Posts
near the bottom,
which is a great way to focus on getting
the crucial content pretty fast.
You'll also notice that we've
been using Compact Mode,
which shows only the topic titles.
You can change that at the bottom.
If you're overwhelmed by the amount
of new content on Piazza and
you just want to start fresh, you can
just click Mark All Read at the bottom.
Lastly, you can also
shortcut these filters.
Ebony has Unread, Updated, Unresolved
and Following shortcutted right here.
You can remove a shortcut
by clicking Remove shortcut
while viewing that filter, and
you can add a shortcut by clicking Add
shortcut while viewing that filter.